david has waited four years for sight of
this report
it is not possible to know how many
children suffered sexual abuse in
football
from 1970 to 2005.
he was targeted by prolific paedophile
coach barry bonnell at butlins holiday
camp
and went there and sexually abused over
both evenings for a prolonged period of
time
and then about a month later he
came home from school and he's sat in my
house uh talking to my mum
and he he just got to me
you know completely psychologically
the abuse may be termed historical but
the psychological trauma is ever present
yeah i wasn't um i wasn't
sort of planning on getting you know
emotional today i spoke about it a lot
the report was commissioned after andy
woodward waved his anonymity to reveal
he'd been sexually abused by barry
bonnell
he didn't find evidence of a conspiracy
to cover up in the game
but its conclusion was damning clyde
sheldon qc
said the football association failed
children for five years
between 1995 and 2000.
he wrote the fa acted far too slowly to
introduce appropriate and sufficient
child protection measures
these are significant institutional
failings for which there is no excuse
barry bonnell abused countless boys at
manchester city and crew alexandra
the clubs the report said must have been
aware of rumors of his abusing
but failed to investigate i'm not able
to say that
dario grady was coaching at crew at the
time and director of football there
until 2019
no i've nothing to say i'm under
instructions
sorry when discussing the general scope
of the abuse with the inquiry
grady said that he did not consider a
person putting their hands down
another's trousers
to be an assault he remains banned from
football by the fa for unspecified
reasons
some survivors provided testimony to the
report stating their belief that there
was a pedophile ring operating within
football
while clive sheldon qc did accept that
some of these perpetrators may have
known each other
he didn't arrive at that conclusion
it was a 700-page report detailing the
abuse of generations of young
footballers
and from the national governing body the
apology survivors had waited for
we have to hold our hands up and
apologize for the mistakes of the past
make sure we don't repeat them but
that's not to say that football is
not in a safe environment today it is
the report does note there's no evidence
that this abuse was commonplace in
football
but for the hundreds of boys whose
dreams were shattered
that will offer little comfort martha
kellner sky news crew